مشاهدينا اهلا بكم قصفت قوات مواليه للواء
الليبي المتقاعد خليفه حفتر ضواحي مدينه
بنغازي بصواريخ جراد بشكل عشوائي وهو ما
اتبعه رد من كتائب الثوار بقصف مناطق
تتمركز بها قوات حفتر نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في محورين اولا الى اي مدى وصل
النزاع المسلح الذي تشهده
ليبيا وما هو تاثير المواجهات المسلحه في
ليبيا على اجراء انتخابات مجلس النواب
المقرره الاربعاء
المقبل قصف يكاد يكون شبه يومي تشهده
مناطق عده في بنغازي شرق ليبيا كان اخره
اليوم عندما قصفت قوات اللواء الليبي
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر ضواحيه في بنغازي
بصواريخ جراد واستتبع رد كتائب الثوار
بقصف مناطق تتمركز فيها قوات حفتر في
المدينه التطورات الجاريه على الارض في
ليبيا اثارت مخاوف بشان تداعياتها على
انتخابات مجلس النواب المزمع اجراؤها في
مختلف المناطق الليبيه يوم الاربعاء
المقبل والتي بدات اليوم في الخارج وسط
امال باخراج البلاد من الوضع الصعب الذي
تعيشه
ليبيا تبدا الانتخابات التشريعيه الليبيه
في الخارج فيقوم مناصر اللواء المتقاعد
خليفه حفتر بقصف عشوائي على ضواح في مدينه
بنغازي بصواريخ جراد فيتصدى ثوار كتيبه
الساب عش من فبراير للهجوم لكن تزامن
الحدثين القصف والاقتراع يعيد الى اهالي
مدن الشرق الليبي ذكريات مع هذا النوع من
الصواريخ ابان ثورتهم على القذافي انذاك
كان الرجل يمطر بهذه الصواريخ وان ذاك
كانوا يتندرون عليها فاذا هي جراد على
لسانهم وفي
تعليقاتهم يذهب القذافي ويطوي الليبيون
الصفحه جراده لياتي بعده من يعيد الامور
الى سيرتها الاولى فالقصف على بنغازي يكاد
يكون شبه يوميا ولم تتراجع وت رم وعود
قطعت بخفض ولاحقا وقفها في يوم الانتخابات
وبعض هذه الوعود صدرت عن حفتر نفسه نحن
حريصين على ان الانتخابات تسير سيرا حسن
حقيقه يعني وبالتالي هم طلبوا منا يعني
محاوله ايقاف اطلاق النار نحن
اصبحنا حتى من الان يعني نحاول قدر
الامكان ان نخفف
العمل اعطاء فرصه
للانتخابات الانتخابات بدات في الخارج
ناخبون يدلون باصواتهم على مدار يومين على
ان يكون الاربعاء المقبل موعد الليبيين في
الداخل لانتخاب برلمان جديد وثمت رهان على
هذا البرلمان بعد ان كان الحالي مصدرا
لتنازع الليبيين ونخبهم السياسيه فالبلاد
تفتقد عمليا مؤسسات الدوله الحقيقيه وكان
البديل فوضى امنيه وغياب التوافق بين
الفرقاء السياسيين ويامل كثير من الليبيين
بان تتحول نتائج الانتخابات الى مرجعيه
يبني عليها الليبيون مؤسسات بلادهم ومنها
بناء جيش وطني يفكك المجموعات المسلحه
ويستوعب كثيرا من عناصرها في صفوفه اضافه
الى ضروره تشكيل حكومه جديده والاسراع في
اقرار الدستور وفي راي كثيرين فان التنازع
بين الشرعيات والتشكيك بها تسبب بالمزيد
من الانقسامات وعرض وحده البلاد للخطر
ووفر بيئه خصبه للمغامرات
العسكريه والحال هذه فان العوده الى شرعيه
الانتخابات توفر الحد الحد الادنى من
التوافق السياسي بين الفرقاء ومن المؤمل
ان تقطع الطريق على اي مغامره عسكريه لا
تؤمن سوى بالقوه لحكم البلاد والحيلوله
دون
انقسامها للمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا هنا
في الاستديو الكاتب الصحفي والناشط
السياسي الليبي الدكتور اسامه كعبار وينضم
الينا من باريس الكاتب والباحث السياسي
الليبي كامل المرعاش نرحب بضيف
من باريس وهنا في الاستوديو وابدا معك
دكتور اسامه كعبار نريد ان نتحدث بدايه ع
ما يجري في ليبيا النزاع المسلح يعني الذي
تشهده ليبيا بين قوات اللواء خليفه
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر وكتائب الثوار لا
يزال مستعرا الى اي مدى سيستمر هل تعتقد
ان له نهايه
سينتهي دامل هذا يعني حسب المعلومات اللي
اصلني ان يعني اخواننا الثوار في في في
بني غازي اي في حاله الاعداد الان ان شنوا
هجوم كامل على منطقه بنينا اللي هي في
القاعده الجويه هديه وعلى منطقه الرجبه
يعني يحاولوا ان
ينظفوا ما حوالين بني غازي ومما تتعرض
عليه من من من قصف يعني نتمنى ايضا ان ان
ان تنتقل البرنامج ينتقل الباقي المدن
الشرقيه شرق بني غازي واحنا يوم امس كان
في صواريخ جراد سقطت على قاع طبرق وهي من
من الثوار يعني لقصف القاعده هذيه حتى لا
يتم استعمالها من قبل الطيران اللي يتبع
السيد حفتر يعني
ا استاذ كامل المرعاش يعني القصف على
بنغازي يكاد يكون شبه
يومي لم تتراجع وتيرته رغم ان اللواء
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر هو بنفسه يعني صدرت
عنه تصريحات او وعود قطعها
بتخفيض يعني القصف على بنغازي ما مدى جديه
خليفه حفتر في تقديم هذه الوعود والالتزام
بها لماذا لم
تنفذ والله اعتقد من يعني من الخطا جدا
تحميل اللواء خليفه حفتر كل هذه الاخطاء
نحن نعرف ان بنغازي او منطقه الشرق الليبي
هي منطقه حرب مفتوحه منذ ان اعلنت معركه
الكرامه
وا لابد نفهم لماذا انطلقت هذه المعركه
لابد ان نفهم اسبابها
ونتفهم الضباط الجيش الليبي الوطنيون
كانوا عرضه للاغتيالات خلال سنتين وا يعني
اغتيل منهم المئات دون ان تحرك الحكومه او
كتائب الوار اي ساكن لمواجهه هذا الخط
يعني الهدف واضح منذ
الا الكرامه معكه الكرامه دعيني لا فقط في
نفس سياق فكرتك استاذ مرع دعيني اكمل هذه
النقطه تفضل تفضل تفضل لا لا يعني لابد ان
نتحدث عن الاسباب التي دعت الى انطلاق
معركه الكرامه اعتقد انه الزخم الشعبي هل
استعيد نعم هي ليس فقط استعاده الامن هو
الضباط هم هناك
سكين على رقاب هؤلاء الضباط هي معركه دفاع
عن النفس قبل ان تكون اي شيء اخر ثم تجاوب
معها الشعب واصبحت مساله لتخليص
بنغازي المدينه المذبوحه المنكوبه من هذا
الداء الذي يقتلها كل يوم دون ان نعرف من
هو القاتل ليس من المعقول ان تصبح يعني
يعني يعني كتائب التوار هي المسؤوله على
الامن ومن ناحيه اخرى نقول انهم ليسوا
مسؤولين يا اخي ربما يكونوا ليسوا مسؤولين
على القتل مباشره ولكن هم مسؤولون اخلاقيا
عن عمليات القتل لماذا لم يقبضوا على شخص
واحد يقوم بعمليات هذه القتل ثم فيه يعني
دلائل وقرائن كثيره تشير الى تنظيم من هذه
التنظيمات هو الذي يقوم بعمليات
الاغتيالات هذا التنظيم نحن لا نقول كل
الثوار هم هذا التنظيم هذا التنظيم ظهر
زعيمه على شاشات العالم و وقال ما قال
وفهم الليبيون هذه الرساله واتضح بشكل غير
مباشر
انهم هذ الاغتيالات وبالتالي حفتر حفتر
يهاجم هذا التنظيم الارهابي الذي اوغل ق
ليبين واضحه جدا الكره دعنا نحول على
الدكتور اسامه كعبار حقيقه هذا هذا الكلام
هراء يا اما هو شخص مغيب يا اما هو شخص
يتبع الثوره المضاده في ليبيا لان كتائب
الثوار اللي كان متواجده في بنغازي لم
تكلف رسميا من المؤتمر الوطني او من راس
اركان بتامين بني غازي لم تكلف عندما كلفت
قامت بتامين الجنوب قامت بتامين الكفره
قامت بتامين سبهه قامت بالاماكن التي تم
بها تكليف ولكن داخل بني غازي كانت جهات
امنيه تتبع الدوله وهي اللي ساهمت في
خلخله الامن داخل بنغازي هذا الكلام هذا
الكلام اللي يقول فيه السيد كامل مراش غير
غير غير صحيح حقيقه وبعيد عن الواقع في
بنغازي طيب الان يعني التحرك الذي يقوده
اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر في بنغازي ضد
ما يسميه اوكار الارهاب والجماعات
التكفيريه
والارهابيه هل على الارض يعني حقق اي تحسن
بالنسبه لسكان الشرق لا بكل تاكيد لم يحقق
ل لو لو حتى حسبنا احنا كم من الشخصيات
اللي هم تم
اغتيالهم ويتبعوا مثلا للجيش لان هناك
شخصيات من الثوار قيادات عسكريه تتبع
القوات المسلحه من الثوار تم اغتيالهم في
نفس الموضوع ولكن لو حس سبنا بالناس اللي
هم قتلوا في عمليه ما يسمى بالكرامه الناس
المدنيين الذين قتلوا هناك اعداد هناك
طبعا العدد العدد فاق ما ما قتل في في
في ليس هناك تقديرات ولكن العدد فاق لان
المعركه لازالت قائمه وفي تعتيم اعلامي
على على الاخبار اللي تطلع من من بني غازي
طبعا لا نريد ان ندخل في دائره التكهنات
والتخمينات والتقديرات غير المؤكده
بالنسبه ل عدد الضحايا اللي سقطوا بعد
عمليه الكرامه لكن على الاقل فيما يتعلق
بتحسن الوضع الامني والسؤال للاستاذ كامل
مرعاش لا تشعر الناس فعلا بانه هناك تحسن
امني حدث منذ بدايه هذه العمليه التي بدات
في شهر مايو يعني ليست عمليه حديثه من
اسبوع او اسبوعين هل على مدار كل
هذا السقف الزمني لم يعني ينتج عن هذه
العمليه اي نتائج ايجابيه ملموسه محسوسه
يشعر بها المواطن ليبي في
الشرق
دعيني في لحظات ان ارد على الارقام
والتكهنات انا لن اخمن ارقام ولن اتكه
بارقام انا اتكلم عن ارقام مؤكده ان هناك
اكثر من
5 ضابط شرطه وامن وناشط سياسي وناشط حقوقي
في بنغازي تم اغتيالهم وقتلهم هذه ليست
تكهنات هذه ارقام واضحه ساعود الى السؤال
الذي طرحتيه العمليه ما زالت في بداياتها
ونحن نعرف ان قتال هذه المجموعات ليس
بالعمليه السهله هم يتواجدون في مناطق
اهله بالسكان وبالتالي حتى من يتحدث عن
القصف العشوائي هذا ليس شيء دقيق القصف
يتم على مناطق معينه اين يتواجد
هؤلاء المجرمون الذين حولوا اهل بنغازي
الى رهينه في ايديهم والى قتلهم وغير ذلك
وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه الان في بنغازي
هذه المجموعات التي تمارس الاغتيال والقتل
والتدمير يجب ان تفكر اكثر من مره للاقدام
على ذلك اذا هناك مساله توازن للرعب في
بنغازي لم نشهده من قبل لانه هذه
المجموعات توغلت وغلت في في في قتل
الليبيين دون ان يكون لها اي ردع نعم طيب
سيد مرعاش يعني خصوم حفتر يتحدث عن نيته
لنقل المعركه الى
العاصمه طرابلس ما مدى صحه مثل هذه
المعلومات التي تروج
الان يعني انا لا اعتقد يعني انا انا لست
من يعني الذين يقولون ان حفتر يستطيع
السيطره على ليبيا وانقلاب عسكري لا ليبيا
اصعب من ذلك بكثير لن
يستطيع يعني مجموعه مسلحه واحده ان تسيطر
على ليبيا لان ليبيا الان هي ساحه مفتوحه
لكل هذه الميليشيات التي تسيطر عليها
افقيا وعموديا وبالتالي من الصعب جدا هناك
لعمليه الكرامه وحفتر هناك تعاطف شعبي
كبير ليس لشخص
حفتر مع هذه العمليه لماذا ت دكتور اسط
شعبي كبير وهناك ايض جهات اخرى السؤال
للدكتور اسامه
فقط حتى نوزع الوقت يعني بشكل ينصف
الضيفين معا دكتور اسامه كعبار يعني اذا
كان هناك فعلا حاضنه شعبيه كبيره هناك
تعاطف شعبي كما يقول الاستاذ مرعاش لهذه
العمليه عمليه
الكرامه على من يقع اللوم اذا لا لا ليس
هناك حاضنه شعبيه كبيره هناك حاضنه شعبيه
نعم هناك من يؤيد حفتر ليس حبا في حفتر
ولكن ولكن رغبه في في في في ايجاد الامن
والامان لان لان ان عموم الشعب مل هذا
الوضع الامني الحاصل فهناك حاضنه نعم ولكن
ليست بحضنه الكبيره وهناك حاضنه شعبيه لا
باس بها ايضا اللي هي تقاتل حفتر وضد حفتر
وضد
ما ما يحصل في بني غازي وفي الشرق يجب ان
ان ان نسمي الامور بمسمياتها حفتر يقود
ميليشيات لا يقود جيش وطني الحكومه ورئاسه
الاركان اصدروا بياناتهم والموت المواطن
اصدر بياناته بكل وضوح ان حفتر خارج عن
القانون و وصادر فيه مذكر لانه لانه عاجز
الجميع عن انشاء جيش يفكك هذه المجموعات
المسلحه ويكون وجها يعني عسكريا للدوله
وجه رسمي هو هو انا اتوافق معك في هذه
النقطه ولكن لا يدعي انه يقود الجيش
الوطني الجيش الوطني هذا مسمى يتبع الدوله
لكنه ملا فراغا موجودا لم يملا اي فراغ
حقيقه لان ما يح ما يقوم به حفتر هو عبث
لم يستطع ان يتقدم شبر بل
هجر المئات من المدنيين وقتل العديد من
المدنيين هو هو قصف جامعات وقصف معاهد
ومخازن
معدات يعني ثلاجات وغسالات لمواطنين ماذا
حقق من محاربه للارهاب لا يعني الان في
نحن في وقت لا تستطيع ان تحارب الارهاب
بارهاب اخر ما يقوم به حفتر هو ارهاب ا
طيب اي سناخذ فاصلا قصيرا الان نناقش بعد
الفاصل مدى تاثير النزاع المسلح على
انتخابات مجلس النواب المقرره قريبا جدا
الاربعاء المقبل لا تذهبوا
بعد مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد الى
هذه الحلقه التي نناقش فيها تداعيات
التطورات الراهنه في ليبيا وتاثيرها
المحتمل على انتخابات مجلس النواب نرحب
بكم وبضي فينا من جديد استاذ كامل المرعاش
والدكتور اسامه
كعبار استاذ كامل مرعاش يعني ثمه رهان قوي
قائم اليوم على الانتخابات النيابيه على
يعني برلمان جديد بوجوه جديده بسياسات
جديده لماذا لا تعطي الاطراف المتصارعه
هذه الانتخابات فرصه حتى يطلع في النهايه
برلمان جديد ويخرج البلاد من الازمه
القائمه فيها بدل دخول في عمليات عسكريه
مثل عمليه
الكرامه
نعم والله كنا امل انه هذه الانتخابات تعد
طوق النجاه ولكن الحقيقه وانا لا اريد ان
اكون متشام يعني الظروف الموضوعيه لاقامه
انتخابات يعني تشريعيه نزيهه وشفافه وتعكس
بالفعل اراده الشعب الليبي غير متوفر في
ليبيا يعني اليوم هذا اليوم سمعت ان
المواد الانتخابيه منعت من الدخول في في
مدينه
درنا وتسالي ضيفك الذي معك من منع دخول
مواد الانتخابات الى مدينه درنا ومن يحكم
مدينه درنا هذا سؤال يوجه الى
اخونا الذي يتحدث عن الشرعيه الذي يتحدث
عن الشرعيه لا يختطفها الذي يتحدث عن
الشرعيه لا يحاصر الوزرات الذي يتحدث عن
الشرعيه لا يختطف رئيس الوزراء الشرعي في
انص في الليالي والذي يتحدث عن الشرعيه لا
يقتحم المؤتمر الوطني العام رمز الشرعيه
والسياده العليا في الدوله ويفرض عليه
قوانين بقوه السلاح وتحت فوهه البنادق
يعني هذه الشرعيه يتحدثون عنها عندما تكون
لينه وتجاريه وتحقق لهم ما يريدون وينفضون
عندما ترفض ما يريدون هذه شرعيه مزيفه
واعتقد ان هذه الميليشيات اصبحت تعتاش على
هذا الوضع وتريد ان تستمر ليبيا في هذا
الوضع ليس لاننا يعني ثوره مضاده او غير
ذلك نناصر هذا الرجل لانه ربما ربما ياتي
لنا بحل ينهي هذه الماساه الذي يعيشها
الليبيون الان تحت ما يسمى التوار يا اخي
توار ثم بعد ذلك هل تريدون اقامه دوله
ودوله قانون ومؤسسات ام
تريدون نعم نحن نؤيد صناديق الاقترا ولكن
من فرض من اوصل البلاد الى هذه الحاله من
هو المسؤول عن خروج حفتر اصلا فنسال هذا
السؤال يجيبني على هذا السؤال معلش اسئلتك
كلها احولها الى الى الدكتور
كعبار اولا بالنسبه لما يحدث في درنا من
المسؤول عنه ثم الى اي مدى يمكن تعويل على
هذه الانتخابات فعلا لا هو هو الان في
الوضع الامني
الحالي يعني هناك علامات استفهام كبيره
على هذه الانتخابات ولكن ليس لنا
اي خيار اخر الا المسير في هذا الطريق ليس
هناك اي خيار اخر لان الخيارات الاخرى
كلها خيارات
انقلابيه الانتخابات من قبل لا بس يعني
الخيارات الاخرى الخيارات
الاخرى نعم بس الخيارات الاخرى يعني على
الاقل المسار الديمقراطي متعثر وفيه مشاكل
ولكن هو مسار ديمقراطي هو خيار لم يكن
خيار الشعب بالكامل فهو خيار شريحه كبيره
من الشعب الخيارات الاخرى هي خيارات
انقلابيه خيارات متامر لما نتحدث عن
المحكم الدستوريه ت تستمل البلاد زي ما
حصل في مصر مثلا او نتحكم نتحدث على مؤتمر
القبائل اللي هو اللي كانوا يعني يسبحوا
بحمد القذافي الان نجيبهم الشخصيات هذيه
ونحطوهم هم يتراس البلاد هذه
كل ما ردك نعم العينه التي تحدث عنها درنا
ن نعم هناك جماعات اسلاميه
تكفيريه تسيطر ممكن لربما على درنا مسيطره
ولكن الثوار الحقيقيين من منذ وتقريبا
اسبوعين حصلت مواجهه بينهم بين الثوار
الحقيقيين وبين الجماعات التكفيريه هذيه
هناك محاوله كبيره من الثوار الى تنقيه
صفوفهم وتنقيه الجماعات هذيه التكفيريه من
من من المدن هذيه يجب ان نعرف شيء واحد ما
يتحدث عنه السيد كامل المعاش حقيقه هو
يحاول ان يضع السم في العسل لان بغض النظر
عن بعض الاشكاليات التي حصلت من حمى وامن
الانتخابات المؤتمر الوطني هم الثوار ا
ومن حمى وامن انتخابات لجنه 60 هم الثوار
ومن يحمي المسار الديمقراطي الان في ليبيا
هم الثوار اذا نحن نسير يعني هم الشرعيه
يمثلون الشرعيه الثوار ا هم يحمون الشرعيه
هم يحمون المسار الديمقراطي مؤسسات رسميه
للدوله من الثوار لا هناك مؤسسات رسميه
يفترض ان تكون هي الضامن لا لا بس المؤس
المؤسسات الرسميه نتحدث الان عن الناحيه
الامنيه الناحيه الامنيه الدوله لا تملك
جيش ولا يفترض يفترض ان يكون هناك شرطه
وجيش ومؤسسات عسكريه وامنيه هناك تقريبا
ال شخص ينتمي لهذه المؤسسات ويتقاضى في
مرتبات ولكن كلهم جالسين في بيوتهم اذا من
من تصدر لهذا المشهد طواعيه هم كتائب
الثوار الشريفه النقيه هناك من تجاوز ولكن
هذول لا يحسبوا على الثوار انا لما اتحدث
عن الثوار اتحدث عن الثوار الشرفاء وهذه
الكتائب معروفه معروفه لد الشعب الليبي
خلينا من الناس اللي حاول تحاول تشكك
وتحاول كذا هذا هو انسان مريض انسان كذا
انا انا لا اهتم طيب بالنسبه ليوم
الانتخابات استاذ كامل مرعاش يعني هذا
الاستحقاق الانتخابي سيجري طبعا وسط ظروف
امنيه صعبه للغايه هل باعتقادك سيكون هناك
هدنه سيلتزم مثلا خليفه حفتر بال الهدنه
يوم الانتخابات على الاقل حتى تصوت الناس
في هذا
اليوم والله انا امل انه سيد حفتر اي ان
يهدئ الاوضاع حتى تجرى الانتخابات في
بنغازي كما اعملل من الاطراف الاخرى التي
تقاتل حفتر ايضا هي ان تلتزم بذلك ولكني
ليس لدي ضمانه ان تجرى هذه الانتخابات في
مدينه درنه او في سرت مثلا ليس هناك هناك
ضمانه ان تقام انتخابات في
هاتين
المدينتين التي اختطفت منذ اكثر من عامين
السيد اسامه يتحدث ان التوار امنوا وامنوا
ار لم يؤمنوا بنغازي لم يؤمنها من القتل
لا لكن لم يؤمنها من القتل المستمر الذي
قتل فيه اكثر من
520 ثم يتحدث عن حمايه الشريه هل الذي
يحمي لحظه يا سيدتي لحظه يا سيدتي هل الذي
يحمي الشرعيه يقوم باختطاف رئيس الوزراء
في انصاف الليل هل الذي يحمي الشرعيه
يقتحم المؤتمر الوطني العام ويفر
يتحدث عن الشرعيه الشرعيه بقوه
السلاح سيد مرعاش ام عبر الصناديق
الاقتراع يذهب الناس يوم الاربعاء يصوتوا
اليوم بدا التصويت في الخارج ويوم
الات الدوله بمؤسسات الدوله لماذا لا تعطى
الفرصه ل بمؤسسات الد بشكل مدني حضاري
وراقي الناس نعم انا مع الانتخابات
الانتخابات هي هي الانتخابات ليست غايه في
حد ذاتها ولكنها اداء للتداول السلمي على
السلطه ولكن هل هناك من يحترم هذه السلطه
هل هناك من يلقي بسلاحه وينضوي تحت مؤسسات
هذه الدوله هذا الذي نريده الانتخابات
ربما هذخ سيتم انتخاب مجلس مرعش هذا
ما يريده
كل ولكن كل شيء عنده ولاكن
يعني ايضا مره اخرى لم يبقى معنا الا ثوان
قليله دكتور كر ه هل سيحترم حتى المؤتمر
الجديد هذا من قبل هذه الميليشيات نعم
ما
الاجو لا ل لن تنتهي هذه المشاكل يعني
احنا لن تكون هناك عصاه سحريه عشان تزيح
كل العقبات ولكن هذا هو المسار الديمقراطي
الذي يجب على الجميع ان يقف وراه اما كلمه
ولكن ولكن هو يبرر لاشياء اخرى واتمنى ان
يفصح عن اتمنى ان يفصح عنها نحن مع المسار
الديمقراطي في ليبيا نحن مع خيار الشعب في
ليبيا ونحن مع الشرعيه في ليبيا وسندافع
لحمايه هذه الشرعيه ولكن ولكن انتهى وقت
البرنامج من يحمي الشرعيه لا يختطف
ر نحن نحن نحم الشرعيه وباذن الله سبحانه
وتعالى ستكون هناك ليبيا باذن الله شكرا
لكما دكتور اسامه كعبار الكاتب الصحفي
والناشط السياسي الليبي وايضا نشكر ضيفنا
من باريس الباحث السياسي الليبي كامل
المرعاش بهذا ناتي الى نهايه هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
في قراءه جديده لما وراء خبر جديد لكم منا
اطيب المنى
والقاء